Where they're not going to know the world that we knew when we were kids.
No Internet,
no fake tits.
Sometimes people were just on attractive.
No one knew anything about diet.
Nobody worked out.
When I was in high school and we fuck them worked,
dudes would like bench press and shit,
but you know like how many women lifted weights?
We were in high school and that the cheerleaders were in good shape.
Yeah,
for a little while.
for a little while and they got nobody.
Don't,
nobody kept going.
Did Rocky really start like the big movement started my boots.
I've read about it,
but I don't know how true it is because I was too way too young.
Dude.
When rocky came out,
I think I was seven and a,
I drank raw eggs and ran around the block and I told Sylvester Stallone that,
that,
that one single bit I 100% did.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I want to be a fighter.
I started drinking eggs and running.
I never ran was seven years old,
man.
Fuck,
am I doing running?
Maybe I was eight.
I had no such effect on top onto to doctor,
to doctor,
to doctor.
Oh was like we're running,
I'm not good.
Right on was amazing.
He goes eight.
I didn't know how old I was,
but I remember it when it came out.
Never been more inspired for something in my life.
I'm moving change the world.
People don't even understand how good it was.
He lives on my street.
That's really,
yeah he does.
He's come on time driving his range rover with a,
with a big cockatiel on his shoulder.
I'm like,
well that's Kinda cool.
There he is running around fucking weights at his hand and shit.
Run with converse all stars.
One of the reasons why I them to this day,
they might not be all stars.
They might be kids.
They might be like some cheap Walmart version.
Who knows?
But this is some fucking epic shit.
In the 1970s what year was this movie?
What?
Let's take a guess.
What year do you think it was?
I wanna say it was like 79 76 76 the spirit of 76 was the rematch.
No,
there was 76,
because that was when Apollo creed six.
Yeah.
I don't middle as exactly doing one nighters across,
uh,
I believe it was Alabama.
We and uh,
he drove a 1970,
he drove the bicentennial Vega.
Right.
So it was a Vega.
The 76 Vega had said 76,
you know,
some things they're doing,
it would,
you know,
celebrate the sesquicentennial or whatever it was the,
um,
no,
so you probably 200 years,
I guess.
I don't know.
A long time.
I was nine years old when this movie came out.
And so that's exactly how old I was.
I gotta tell you these techniques aren't that good.
So it needs to tighten up on his swing.
Like the ways throwing punches like three he need needed a coach.
He needed a coach.
Well,
he got one and Carl weathers,
this was,
uh,
in rocky two,
rocky to Carl weathers became his Po.
Was it rocky three?
Three.
Right,
because that was when he fought ms teen.
Yeah,
that's right.
Right.
Yeah.
For his day.
A woman you're willing to say,
man,
ain't got no heart.
I bet just stay up every night was she had a real man.
Bring your pretty little self holding my apartment tonight and I'll show you a
real man.
You probably would have to,
oh,
I couldn't believe he was saying that to rocky.
Right,
right.
It was like if he was saying that to a Wahoo McDaniel.
Yeah,
man.